MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Managing a city
requires lots of infrastructure,
both physical and technical.
Join us in historic
downtown Austin, Texas,
as we talked to SADA systems
about their dotMaps solution
for managing projects.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
John, thanks so much
for joining us today.
Tell us a little
bit more about SADA.
JOHN BLESAK: Yeah,
so SADA kind of
started with a really
kind of basic partnership,
with Google--
let's say upwards
of 10 years ago,
maybe even a little bit more--
kind of being one of their
trusted resellers for Google
Maps and G Suite and then
ultimately Google Cloud.
I think we've become one of
their kind of go-to services
partners in the space,
where they can kind of rely
on SADA to help bring an
implementation of, like I said,
kind of Maps, G Suite on Google
Cloud from start to finish.
Obviously, Google gives these
great tools for companies
to build products
and build workflows.
But they don't necessarily
get into the services world
with it.
So they need these
trusted partners, I think,
that have a lot of experience
and developers and engineers
that Google can trust to help
bring those projects, again,
from start to finish and
allow for a proper rollout
and a proper implementation.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Tell
me a little bit more
about what dotMaps does.
What are the selling
points for it?
JOHN BLESAK: Yeah, so
dotMaps is focused--
it's kind of a more
of a niche product
where it kind of has a
specific need within the city.
Most of these cities,
what they have is they
need to coordinate capital
improvement projects that
are internal to the city.
So those are repairs
to streets and roads
and things like that--
signs and signals.
And then they also have to
coordinate those internal city
projects with outside
utility groups,
such as gas and electric,
water, and things like that.
The biggest problem these
cities have is basically
aligning with those
utility groups that
are on the outside
of the coordination
efforts within the city.
And I think giving an
application that really
incentivizes these groups to
work together and collaborate
on an easy-to-use platform is
why we're seeing such great ROI
numbers with dotMaps.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what
does dotMaps actually do?
Like, what does it involve
when people use it?
JOHN BLESAK: So,
really, at its core,
dotMaps is going to be
conflict resolution.
So really, what you
have right now is
you've got a city that needs
to dig up First Street,
and they have a major project.
But you also have these
other outside groups
that need to do work in the
city and the right of way
in addition to the city.
So being able to
properly coordinate
that work between the city
and share materials and costs
and make sure that you
don't have groups showing up
to a construction site at the
same day at the same time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So this is kind
of like a tool that
helps centralize
all of those different things
going on at once to communicate
them better.
How has the reception been
for the tool besides just ROI?
JOHN BLESAK: Reception
has been great.
Again, I think the adoption
rates speak volumes.
I think in DOT, your adoption
rates are everything.
If you can't get people
excited and on board
properly to these
softwares, they
tend to end up in kind
of the IT graveyard,
I kind of call it, within DOT.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What makes
the DOT and public sector
as a whole different from the
rest of, well, private sector?
JOHN BLESAK: I would say just
their willingness to take risks
with some software.
Like I was saying,
I think that they've
been kind of duped
to some extent
by some vendors over
the last couple decades
when it comes to software.
And I think that
they really want
to mitigate risk as
much as possible,
especially when you're using
taxpayer money and government
money to be buying these
pieces of software.
So if you can get in there
and show that you can actually
do what you're saying and
prove that out and then
really generate some
real ROI numbers,
I don't see there's any
reason why the DOT wouldn't
continue to work with you.
But it's all about
proving that you
can do what you're saying
that your product can
do before the city, I think,
trusts you enough to say,
let's go to some of these
more robust use cases,
these more high dollar
infrastructure projects--
things like that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
that's a big reason
that dotMaps has
been so successful.
JOHN BLESAK: Absolutely.
I mean, I think, again,
it's all about the ease
of use of dotMaps.
It's a very, again,
niche product.
And I think there's not a lot
of players that are doing it
as well as we are.
And if you can get in there, and
you can see big wins in cities,
like Chicago and Seattle,
you can prove out
that you can work with any
size city at that point--
cities with a lot
of one-way streets,
cities with a ton
of construction,
cities with tons of cranes
and construction management
going on.
Those are big use
cases for these cities.
And there's millions
of dollars at stake
and then making sure that
you get these projects done,
coordinated.
And then really communicate
it out to the public,
as well, I think is crucial.
You know, the
government always wants
to try and be transparent to
some extent with the public
and let them know
what's going on.
That's why with dotMaps,
we actually rolled out
a public portal as well.
So there's a very easy to
use Google-based map type
public portal where anybody
that's living in that city
can go in and actually
subscribe to their regions,
figure out when construction
is going to be happening.
If I'm a business
owner, I can also
set up alerts and emails
that will come through.
So if roads or the
right of way is
going to be shut down
in front of my business,
I'd like to know that.
So those are just some of
the ways that we're being--
or helping, I guess,
the government
be more transparent
about what they're doing.
And, again, just kind of
keep that flow of information
going from, not only the DOT,
but also to the public as well.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
Well, John, thank you so much
for coming in and telling us
more about public
sector in the cloud.
JOHN BLESAK: Yeah,
appreciate your time.
Thanks so much.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for watching,
and stay tuned as we
continue to talk with SADA
about public sector solutions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]